take your time we've got plenty of never
mind hurry up what's going on Dad I mean
no she's baby Nick Foles I think a
mutual change will benefit us both I
agree I believe it had good terms yo
they say the kid is special oh wow the
world sure is interesting
Sean Pat ah ankle sprained
still moving I have a mirror that bad
things we need to take him to Arizona
but it's been overrun by philadelphians
wow another beautiful day in the zombie
apocalypse
[Music]
they're connected into one toxic hive
mind it's very scary
sorry I'm Hometown Here song Ready okay
do you still do that I'll try oh this
sounds so rude
jabroni thought he got me you've been
infected with eagle Mania no no I can
stop this John I mean thing
it's just a single Castle
I think now might be a good time to give
us some weapons
illegal hurting of the main character no
it's not cool to say but his kid is
getting annoyed this should be a fun
level I mean look they've got Runners
and All-Pro wide-outs I thought those
were instant
uh hurts her even though I'm a Zombie
I'm still very hot I don't know then you
do need some defense
damn right I'm on fire oh wow two young
guys making the most of a tough
situation speaking of finding love in a
hopeless place stick around for fedra
presents the Rihanna half fight show
a battery time's up oh wait this watch
is busted but time's yours
Tariq take if you found this then I'll
guard to a better place or at least
Miami
I used to hate the world but I was wrong
because there was one person worth
saving me
I wonder how I write it back